[Music]
here we go okay okay well thank you so
much first of all I just want to say for
coming to Ohio day yeah I want to say
you're welcome I mean I've been trying
to get more more things like this to
happen out here so it says it's actually
a lot harder than you think so it's
really nice thank you so much
yeah I wanted to this was my request I I
felt like this movie specifically is
something that I think that everyone in
the country will will be able to respond
to and I you know I Drive across the
country whenever I possibly kings I
think is a filmmaker to actually be
outside of New York in LA and and meet
the audience you're actually making the
movies work is crucial I'm not really
sure how you do it any other way
you physically drive yeah I drove that
the last time I did it was right after
escrow came out Derek and I drove from
LA to Vermont and that's where we built
to wrestle to was on that drive so it
was great but we also we stopped in a
lot of small towns and here you see
these one screen movie theatres in the
middle of Iowa that are showing a movie
and for one of the 50s film prints are
we'll be in one of these small towns and
so as a bill nerd I get excited that's
great yes awesome
well I like to book every quite a bit I
guess it a few days ago thanks I think
it's a really unconventional movie when
finding it are you trying to go for
something unconventional that audiences
are going to be surprised by I feel like
audiences are demanding and right now I
think that we're all so accustomed to
the way the stories are told were so
savvy about it we know when that first
act is going to break you know I think
that it's a responsibility for
filmmakers to keep making new and
original stories and I think for me
since I've I've been so fortunate in
being able to make new versions and
things that we all love right I
personally feel like I have a
responsibility to to make something
truly original in do whatever I can to
just so people can know what I
and for and what kind of a filmmaker I
am sure I think originality can often
come from the first replay anyone ever
writes that it's it's just like the
essence of them and this is a 20 year
old screenplay it was wow this writers
first script to spread Horlicks Gregor
was a novel is really successful
thriller novelist but he has had the
script over all the time and he kept
tweaking and kept changing it and then
when I found it I have just found
something elemental in it and then I
really loved it felt like an old Grimm's
fairy tale or even like a Bible story or
something that just like it's been
around forever and and we even though we
altered a lot together it still had that
like fire of like a first-time writer in
the way that Derek scripted to the
United States not guarantee was just it
could have only been written by their
economy without getting into like plot
points and stuff there's a harsh total
shift I'm curious from a directorial
standpoint how you bridge those gaps in
a film without making it feel too
jarring for an audience I think it
probably will feel drunk for some people
and it's something that I you know I
won't I try to avoid as much as possible
but it was a very difficult line to walk
but the whole thing it's just a tie rope
all the way through and I think what's
most important is is that there are
elements of the totem that it evolved
into in the first half and there are a
lot of elements of the tone that it came
from in the second half so they feel
that they're married together I think on
rewatch there's so many things that are
layered into the movie that allow it to
to go where it goes
that I think it's it is a little
startling at first television is doing
it really well yeah right now and I feel
that we've reached this point where
we're almost now expecting television to
kill off our favorite characters is
there a remedy oh no not not him I've
heard exact
and yet I think in film we have stuff to
this I don't want to say formula but
we've stuck to a certain kind of
structure and set a rules that were in
screenwriting books 20 years ago and has
not changed and you know there are there
are things we do in this movie that we
break rules that are in the first
chapter of the screen writing books but
I in this movie and I feel like it's
almost the only way to surprise people
anymore to do something unexpected or is
to take a states note guaranteed to not
narratively support something you know
the ending was was not built into this
to the constructor of movie and in this
case just pulling the rug out from
people and disorienting them and have
the audience even wondering like is this
going off the rails like this movie
going to be okay and then I I think we
stick the landing at you know I saw it
last night for the first time in a
couple months and my my impression of
the movie coming into it from the
outside was this feels like a gymnast
who does something some crazy flip and
then land and you don't know what she's
going to fall her out and she had a
fling and then she she hits it like
right at the end of it maybe it was
exhilarating for me that we were you
know you guys were getting the only loss
on this I'm curious how how much
direction season pro like her needs or
is she just there she's ready or he just
have to kind of like push her and
certain way attend certain things and
she's just ready to go she just it's
more just conversation why are we doing
what we are doing where where did this
where was this character and see before
where is she going
how can how does this connect to an
experience that you had you know Naomi
has two boys and so it's a really
personal movie for I would imagine him
and she allowed herself kind of stripped
vanity away she allowed herself to she
gets pretty pretty wrecked in this movie
and that was something that I think it
you just go along with her because you
see that she's just on this descent
potentially into like madness at a
certain point and I think it makes you
care for that much more I'm curious if
you have advice for working with younger
actors because this is the second time
now that you've got really good
performance at
about Jurassic world kids were great
kids a greatness I'm even better in this
film Jacob Tremblay was really good
Maddie Ziegler Tigris Ziggler Ziggler I
thought she was a standout here yeah I
agree
I mean there's something about I always
loved surrounding myself with people who
have something to prove because then
you're going to get something like it
and all young artists feel that way they
do
I never despecialized a tease last
performance as a child because he's in
it but he's like 14 in that movie and it
was Maddie's first film but in the same
way I'm taking that guarantee and all of
us had something to prove and you just
you've got the the foundation of
everyone that we're all Energy exactly
and and she's got a lot of dialogue in
the movie she's a character that's been
it's in a horrible place in her life and
for her to be able to communicate all
that through just looks and single words
was really impressive the talent show
Fame in particular I thought was
probably my favorite in the film I'm
used to structuring a film to like build
up to the you know the big action scene
to Joanna and this is this is the same
way but it's built up to you know an
action sequence that's you know between
two houses in a school at the end all
town you got to work with being Norris
also I think is one of most underrated
actors working today it's great I think
he's phenomenal Breaking Bad obviously
gave him a lot more press than he used
to have I'll go back now and watch like
the x-files or something and also seeing
him pop up at a random role as like cop
number two it's so amazing I'm curious
how you got to him for the role of Glenn
tichelman I had actually I finished in
him even on Dragic was up to play the
role in pitch now really really yeah and
he would have been great that desert
great but I thought this is an awesome
job and so even on this next movie I
immediately led to him and I think
there's something about something about
his presence on the screen where
whatever character he's playing you
immediately you really get it right away
and even though he's a villain you know
in this film we wanted to make sure that
he didn't come off as some kind of
mustache twirling evil guy at the
beginning and so you know in situations
like that there's the child abuse in the
film it's not depicted but you know
what's going on and and so often and
it's the most underreported crime like
so often it's just the neighbor next
door who just seems potentially like the
most grounded nice guy in the world and
I think that's that's one of the
scariest things for me is like that that
darkness that's happening behind you
know the door that's next to you yeah
I'm scary that brings me to the
marketing of the movie because I could
imagine this would be a difficult film
to market it was very hard to on the
market there's different crowds there's
different different right one
demographic might really like part of it
another demographic might really like
another part of it did you have a lot of
people to convince basically you know we
always do it was going to be a challenge
and you make the movie before you really
get into those questions and so once we
had the film and we were all really
happy with it and we test it we do the
audience's love the movie and we had all
the pieces but we didn't know what to
tell them what not to tell us we ended
up making a trailer that gave everybody
really the first act and a third act of
the movie and we don't tell you what
happens in the middle what happens the
middle recontextualizes everything and
we felt like it was a for an audience
that I believe is really yearning for
original stories especially in movie
theaters to be able to to make people
think they know what's going on and then
really not want to say jarvan but kind
of you know flip it upside down at a key
point in the middle and I think they'll
be just feeling up oh my god
nobody's safe I felt that way when I
thought and that's a impression that
like you said
some don't have because you walk into a
film nowadays you can pretty much tell
like my wife she does this all the time
she'll be like yeah we just saw a Wonder
Woman she pointed out a character and
went I had already seen it twice and she
wanted that that I went yeah how do you
know that
no no because she could just figure
these dead areas to go away oh yes yeah
and she did and I was like yes why did
you say that
so yeah it's cool you're making a film
that's that's different that people
aren't going to be able to predict them
for a moment one I feel like to me
that's the selfie point okay if we're
going to tell it I mean you know we have
posters all the stuff you have to do but
if I'm gonna lure people to go see the
movie yeah it's not just original but it
will surprise you and if you'll think
about it after you see atomized enough
people have seen it now that I get
emails five six seven days later of
people who are it's finally settling in
and they see I have not been able to get
this movie out of my mind I'm trying to
figure out good about it it won't go
away and and hopefully it will you know
hopefully it'll age well if not be it's
not really well too late well you
mentioned that the posters one of the
posters is like a very paint that almost
Drew Struzan an old-school Hamblin style
closer the do the amylin thumbs have
something important to you and your
guards your upbringing of films that you
we do they do but they also they really
just represent the euro that I grew up
in so when you have you know kids riding
bikes around at a time when things were
safe and to me the end it really isn't
you have exceeded it's not an ambulatory
at all
but it does have that sense of you know
the maps given you know you obviously
have a girl who everybody is trying to
save she's ultimately saved by the
strength of her community and I think
that's something that that people all
around the country can can get into you
know we all we all rely on our
communities yes a to me is it's the
heart of the movies that when you're a
kid you have this the sense of
righteousness because the world is all
black and white yeah there's good and
there's evil it's very simple for me and
I think we all miss that a little bit
like it's adults you just know it's more
complicated that now things are gray and
I almost wish they go back
time when I just knew exactly what was
right and wrong and and when it comes to
when when Naomi finally says you were
only a child you know it's I feel like a
movie like this especially if suspense
thriller and it is you know if you ever
see it again you'll see how it is
structured like a suspense towards
edited like one and it's all the fun
that comes down to this one you know key
moment and that idea that you know
violence is the mindset of a child I
think in this moments as we see you know
violence all around us I think it was
just a potent idea it wasn't mine I was
he was always in the script that that
key idea and we made us find a line that
capsulated it but it really grabbed me
is it as a movie for this moment my last
question is just a random question canto
people to book of Henry and coming out
of June 16th what's the last great new
movie that you saw on the last great new
movie that I saw I loved Lester I love
to sing Street during my oh my god it
was so good it's so good I've seen it
many many I got to see it in a theater
at alone no one else came really whole
theater to myself it was amazing okay
that was that was kind of my movie last
year I thought your we were we got to
watch get out when the whole Jurassic
group got together I thought that was
yeah that was good well thank you so
much man I really appreciate it don't
have to meet you alright
good luck with the movie thank you no
matter what so I'm not panicking
we have to make it better
[Music]
you